como representaría es la cantidad -
james menos x en la recta numérica
considera que la recta numérica está
dibujada a escala vamos entonces a
pensar donde se encuentra esta expresión
matemáticas tenemos primero - y que
sería este punto vamos a ponerlo con
color magenta empezamos en menos yen y
restaremos x
si nosotros restamos iremos hacia la
izquierda recuerdan y este x es positivo
entonces estaremos restando
efectivamente hacia la izquierda x
llegaremos a menos x vamos a ver cuál de
estas respuestas nos da la información
correcta empieza en que se mueve x
unidades a la izquierda es incorrecto es
dado que empezamos en menos ya se
acuerdan esta no empieza en menos y
muévete el valor absoluto de menos x que
será x unidades a la izquierda nos
movimos a la izquierda el valor absoluto
de x ésta suena correcta vamos a ver la
siguiente empieza en positivo y muévete
x unidades a la derecha ahí estaríamos
haciendo una suma de y más x esta es
incorrecta vamos a con la última
respuesta empieza en menos lo cual es
correcto empezamos en menos y muévete el
valor absoluto de menos x que será x
unidades a la derecha sin embargo no
estamos restando menos x cuando restamos
un número positivo nos vamos hacia la
izquierda pero cuando restamos un número
negativo nos vamos hacia la derecha que
es lo que en este caso nos está diciendo
por lo tanto la respuesta correcta será
empiecen menos 9 es el valor absoluto de
menos x unidades a la izquierda